Mark sawatka is the General Secretary of
the PCS Union and he joins us now from
West Wales thank you so much for talking
to us this morning
um you met now I know you're in Wales
but you met remotely with Jeremy Quinn
Minister for the cabinet office this
morning what came of that meeting
uh well good morning to you and your
viewers
um well I'm sad to say the meeting was a
complete fast
we were invited to the meeting after the
Prime Minister indicated a few days ago
that he wanted constructive talks to try
to avert industrial action in the public
sector
um what we got this morning was a
meeting with the minister who confirmed
that he recognized the civil service has
had the lowest pay rate anywhere in the
economy we have some of the lowest rates
of pay 40 000 people using food banks 45
000 people in the Civil Service claiming
inward benefits and yesterday tens of
thousands of civil servants got an email
to say their pay would go up because the
national minimum wage was increasing
because their pay is so low and yet what
he told us today is there's no money on
the table the government is not
considering alleviating this crisis by
any means now including one-off payments
or finding extra money all he will talk
about is 2023's pay and all of the
unions present made it clear that if
that remains the government's position
industrial action is likely to escalate
because we have to do something about
this poverty now and the minister
confirmed this morning that he has no
intention of doing anything about it now
nothing for 2022 but what did they offer
for 2023 pay 23 24. nothing what they
told us is that they might try to be
creative in 2023 they listen to what we
said but we'd have to have discussions
at the appropriate time and the reason
why that is so incredibly frustrating
and outrageous actually is that the
minister knows that he has people
involved in deciding Asylum claims
paying Universal Credit keeping our
justice system running uh keeping the
department for Education offsted museums
and galleries right across the economy
he knows those people are claiming
benefits uh really really struggling and
have a crisis of mental health issues
and physical issues because their pay is
so low and yet he's saying I'm not doing
anything about it and that means the
government seems to be choosing whether
it's in health education or the Civil
Service to say we are prepared to accept
this level of poverty and the disruption
that is going on and I think most people
hopefully will take the view that is an
appalling thing for the government of
this country to do
okay well let me put to you what a
camera office spokesperson has said
following your meeting with Jeremy Quinn
the meeting included discussions to help
ensure fair and affordable public sector
pay settlements we regret the PCS
decision to call further strike action
but discussions will continue and we
have comprehensive plans in place to
keep essential Services running and to
minimize disruption so let's break this
down first of all what's your reaction
to to that
I think that is an utterly misleading
statement it is a political statement
that is trying to give the impression
that there's ongoing conversations when
what they know is that every union today
asked a very simple question do you have
money now to alleviate the crisis the
answer was no every Union asked the
question do you have plans to do
something about the crisis in the Civil
Service and the answer was no and
therefore you know people can be invited
to meetings as often as they like but if
there's nothing available to about the
crisis it must mean that the government
is prepared to accept the disruption and
the poverty that they know that exists
okay let's talk about fair and
affordable because that's the phrase
that they keep coming up with the
government say that the unions have to
come up with a fair and affordable
um settlement
if there is no money and that is what
you say they keep telling you they have
no money what are you asking for and
what do you think is fair and affordable
so the first thing to say is if they say
there's no money available that is a lie
let's just call it what it is that is a
lie why do you say that because we all
know everybody knows there is money
available if they choose to make it
available we've seen in the Wales for
example at the Welsh government is
trying to find money from very stressed
resources to deal with the problems in
the Health Service it's a matter of
political priority this government was
prepared to borrow hundreds of billions
of pounds to give tax cuts to the
richest we're asking for a tiny fraction
of what they would have borrowed then so
what specifically what specifically are
you asking for because the argument is
if we keep borrowing keep borrowing
inflation will go up and we'll just
carry on in this situation the
government's argument is that they have
to cut inflation to sort it all out so
what specifically are you asking for in
terms of the paywrites that you that
you'd want so the first thing is the
government caused inflation let's be
clear about that the government's
mishandling of the economy double
people's mortgages there so that is on
the government and nothing can escape
that and pay raises to public sector
workers do not cause inflation and they
help fight the recession because our
members as we just heard from your
previous report spend the money they get
in the local economy they don't put it
in the Cayman Islands we've asked for a
10 pay raise to reflect the fact that if
we get less than the rate of inflation
we are poorer at the end of the year
than we were at the start but we've said
to the government don't duck the
argument by saying we can't afford 10 if
you say there is money available we will
talk to you night and day to try to
avert the strike they have to say that
they will find money we are prepared to
negotiate how much that is how it's
distributed but it has to happen now and
the government are effectively saying
the penny will be found